the small southern California town of
Solvang is famous for its Danish style
architecture and holiday displays this
time of year transforms itself into one
of the country's most festive Christmas
villages now Jamie yuccas shows us how a
high-tech display is using drones for
the first time to light up the sky the
night sky lit up with the joy and humor
of the holidays in a town that honors
that feeling all year long
[Music]
some call it a Christmas market but to
the Danish it's Yule fest and in solving
a tiny town of about six thousand
they've kept their traditions alive
since Danish immigrants first settled
here in 1911 even today great attention
is paid to customs and festivals solving
Mayor Ryan Tucson when people want to do
over-the-top Christmas this is the place
to be the sights bring visitors from all
over the world one of the most
satisfying crowd pleasers the
traditional Christmas Danish an
aebleskiver the best don't ever take it
off this year the city decided to take
the holiday to new heights with a fleet
of a hundred synchronized drones
remarkably all piloted by one Operator
and a laptop it looks like a mess if you
have never seen it before but it's
pretty organized chaos and we know where
each drone should be doing that whole
procedure
Kyle DeRose Firefly drones is behind
this aerial achievement his quad copters
create shapes some 300 feet tall and can
handle winds up to 25 miles per hour
he says it's rare that a drone goes
rogue is it cool to be a nerd I think so
yeah it's the coolest
while solving x' holiday spectacle has
always attracted lots of fans
it's that melding of Technology and
tradition that's why we knew crowds I
felt they were 3d they were coming
towards us I didn't expect that at all
event coordinator Scott schumake chose
the music and dubbed the show Aurora
droney Alice Christmas is about magic
buried deep inside all of us is those
memories of growing up and those
memories of family my goal was to try
and pull those out and inspiring the
spirit of the season maybe the best
present yet
would you want to see it again for CBS
this morning Jamie yuccas solving
California again apparently this was
very difficult work for Jamie
our reporter Robin singer our producer
and Jamie's dog there knows to enjoy
nice when you get a chance to do stuff
like this yeah and I visited that town
it is absolutely remarkable it's really
cool dance for Christmas yeah you've
been everywhere I've been everywhere to
make sure very long a good life
you